[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka guten abend in
normalen zeiten ist es ein normaler
vorgang dass der einkommensteuertarife
an die inflation angepasst wird um die
berüchtigte kalte progression
auszugleichen
zur erinnerung preise steigen man
fordert eine lohnerhöhung kommt die auch
uhr aber dann kommt das böse erwachen
wegen der inflation hat man mit dem
höheren einkommen nicht mehr kaufkraft
zugleich rutscht man aber in einen
höheren steuertarif von der kalten
progression kalt erwischt sozusagen wie
gesagt dass das bundesfinanzministerium
diesen effekt auszugleichen versucht ist
ein normaler vorgang und auch keine
spezielle idee des aktuellen
finanzministers lindner aber in diesen
nicht normalen zeiten ist sein
steuerplan hochpolitisch und umstritten
dazu gleich ein interview mit ihm nach
dem bericht von frank buchwald
sommer in berlin lehrt der
finanzminister zur pressekonferenz auch
mal in den garten seines ministeriums
nimmt man sorgt sich hohe inflation
steigende energiepreise der minister
schlägt deshalb ein inflationsausgleich
gesetz vor für viele menschen ist das
tägliche leben sehr viel teurer geworden
wir befürchten steigende preise für gas
und energie und lebensmittel zugleich es
auch die wirtschaftliche perspektive
unseres landes fragil geworden wir sehen
das auch das wirtschaftliche wachstum in
den prognosen nach unten korrigiert wird
linde plant entlastungen von rund zehn
milliarden euro unter anderem die
anhebung des grundfreibetrags
eine erhöhung von kindergeld und
kinderfreibetrag sowie änderungen im
steuertarif
dabei geht es vor allem um die
sogenannte kalte progression
sie entsteht wenn lohnerhöhungen sofort
von der steuer weggefressen
das trifft besonders niedriger einkommen
hier steigt die steuerkurve besonders
steil an wenn dann möchte sie etwas
abflachen davon profitieren vor allem
mittlere einkommen
der spitzensteuersatz oberhalb von gut
60.000 euro soll bleiben wie er ist zur
fairness gehört auf der einen seite
diejenigen zu sehen die solidarität
bedürfen und von uns empfangen auf der
anderen seite dürfen aber auch nicht
diejenigen vergessen werden die von den
ergebnissen ihrer schaffenskraft viel
abgeben um den sozialen frieden in
unserem land zu erhalten der spd chef
signalisiert zustimmung auch wenn im
detail manches noch zu klären bleibe es
ist richtig dass er das getan hat das ja
auch zeigt wir wollen jetzt ordentlich
geld in die hand nehmen ich sage aber
auch ganz klar für uns als spd der fokus
muss bei denjenigen liegen die kleine
mittlere einkommen haben die wirklich
hart von dieser krise betroffen sind und
da werden wir jetzt im detail mit dem
finanzminister darüber reden der grüne
koalitionspartner hingegen sieht linden
das entlastungspläne skeptisch wie viel
geld kommt an sind das 100 euro oder 500
euro und der vorschlag der den herr
lindner gemacht hat der hat eine
richtung und die heißt je mehr ich
verdiene umso mehr wird am ende des
jahres auch bei mir ankommen und das ist
aus unserer sicht nicht gerecht das
sieht die linke in der opposition ganz
ähnlich es ist ein unseriöses angebot
mit dem die menschen auch über den tisch
gezogen werden denn 70 prozent der
bevölkerung werden von diesen
sogenannten entlastung gar nichts oder
nur sehr wenig haben anders lindner sein
vorschlag entlaste 48 millionen menschen
in deutschland sagt der minister selbst
in der koalition aber wird er wohl noch
eine menge überzeugungsarbeit leisten
müssen
und da ist der bundesfinanzminister
guten abend herr lindner guten abend
frau slomka hätte die politik befürchtet
dass wir in heißen herbst bekommen viele
menschen gucken mit angst darauf was die
heizkosten rechnungen sie erwarten
werden das ist wirklich eine kritische
situation passt dass da in die
landschaft einem steuer bereinigung zu
machen die vor allem den
besserverdienenden zu gute kommt sie
kommen nicht vor allem den
besserverdienenden zu gute sondern es
ist ein
auf eine steuererhöhung die sonst
heimlich stattfinden würde aber lassen
sie uns die dinge gerne sortieren in
diesem jahr zwei große entlastungs
pakete geschnürt die umfassende
einmalzahlungen für hartz-iv-empfänger
die umfassen einen zuschuss für
wohngeldempfänger rückwirkende
steuerentlastungen im nächsten jahr wird
es eine große wohngeldreform geben und
wir werden die lebenssituation von
menschen in der grundsicherung durch das
neue bürgergeld habe jetzt waren die
steuertarife ich wollte es eben im
zusammenhang darstellen wir haben auf
der einen seite menschen die unsere
solidarität brauchen und wir haben auf
der anderen seite die arbeiten der mitte
in unserem land die viel an steuern und
sozialabgaben zahlen und die möchte ich
schützen vor einer automatischen
steuererhöhungen wenn wir nichts tun
werden 48 millionen deutsche um zehn
milliarden euro in der inflation
belastet und das muss abgewendet werden
die gesamtsumme betrachtet ist das dann
zum teil gar nicht so viel aber
entscheidend ist ja die
verteilungswirkung die das hat also wenn
ich wenig verdiene überhaupt keine
steuern zahle habe ich davon schon mal
gar nichts das sind aber die die momente
echte inflation ja besonders getroffen
werden dann wenn man sich den tarif
anguckt bis 25.000 euro hat man hat es
nur 213 euro entlastung und wenn man
viel verdient 200.000 euro und mehr dann
bekommt man über 670 euro entlastung das
ist eine verteilungswirkung dieser tarif
hat hätte man da nicht etwas anders dran
schrauben können also menschen
brauchen moment eigentlich keine
entlastung die kriegen ihre bude schon
geheizt frau slomka um die menschen die
ihre bude nicht geheizt bekommen da
kümmern wir uns ja mit dem neuen
wohngeld und es gibt bürger geld für die
menschen in grundsicherung aber hier
geht es nun darum nichts anderes zu tun
als unser steuersystem anzupassen an die
inflation die starken schultern werden
weiter auch eine große last tragen aber
sie werden eben nicht stärker belastet
und vor allen dingen sorgen wir dafür
dass nicht menschen die in wahrheit
keine breiten schultern haben durch die
inflation plötzlich mehr steuern zahlen
ist eine reine inflations ansprach soll
diese zehn milliarden gehen zum größten
teil eben an die dann kommt er rein
rechnerisch schon rein rechnerisch
zahlen die höheren einkommen eben auch
das gros des steueraufkommens jemand der
keine steuern zahlt den kann ich
natürlich auch nicht im steuerrecht in
irgendeiner form profitieren lassen das
geht nicht sondern hier geht es darum
steuererhöhungen abzuwenden aber und da
war ihre zahl eben unrichtig ich habe
einen deckel eingezogen bei
62.000 euro jahreseinkommen endet die
zusätzliche
entlastung bzw ab dort gibt es keinen
zusätzlichen vorteil mehr es kann das
ein wirklich euro im vergleich das 113
euro stimmt doch nein die maximale
entlastung bei einem bei einem bei einer
einzelnen person sind 62.000 euro
jahreseinkommen bei 479 euro da ist das
gedeckelt und das ist das 1,5 fache etwa
das 1,5 fache des mittleren einkommens
in deutschland ab diesem punkt gibt es
keine weitere entlastung bzw ab da
verschieben verschiebe ich den
tarifverlauf nicht nochmal
eine wichtige information noch geben die
kalte progression ist in den letzten gut
zehn jahren immer ausgeglichen worden
ein sozialdemokratischer vorgänger hat
sogar noch den letzten tarif wert auf
277.000 euro erhöht ich als liberaler
finanzminister sagen wir machen einen
deckel bei 62.000 euro und deshalb sage
ich das ist sozial ausgewogen umgekehrt
muss man sagen die menschen die 34 5000
euro verdienen ihre heizkosten selbst
bezahlen auch unter der inflation leiden
aber gleichzeitig noch steuern und
sozialabgaben in erheblichen umfang
zahlen die wollen wir noch stärker über
das steuerrecht belasten durch
unterlassung das kann ich nicht fair
finden das steuerrecht muss einen
ausgleich bringen zwischen den menschen
sagt arid empfangen und die alles
bezahlen aber bei der mehrwertsteuer
stört sie das ja auch nicht dass der
staat sich dann quasi durch die
inflation bereichert um sie zu zitieren
ja aber in der tat
nutzen wir ja die möglichkeiten etwa mit
einmalzahlungen wie der energiepreis
pauschale in diesem jahr mit
heizkostenzuschuss um den ausgleich zu
machen um auf inflations gewinne zu
verzichten haben wir in diesem jahr ja
bereits auch den tank rabatz gemacht
damit die leute die höhere spritpreise
bezahlen nicht auch noch über höhere
mehrwertsteuer die staatskasse füllen
dann alle dass manche sagen in dieser
tank rabatt ist das nicht die gratis
mentalität von der sie in bezug auf das
9 euro ticket sprachen ich glaube an der
zapfsäule sieht man dass das sehr teuer
ist das auto vollzutanken
gerade für die pendlerinnen und pendler
und ich hätte es nicht gerecht gefunden
dass die menschen den höheren
weltmarktpreis für den sprit bezahlen
auf diesen höheren preis kommt noch die
mehrwertsteuer und füllt die kasse des
finanzministers aber einige konzerne
gewinnen dadurch aber eine über gewinn
steuer wollen sie auch nicht machen die
konzerne wie etwa bp heißen ja nicht
bayerisch petroleum sondern british
petroleum oder beyond petroleum heute
die haben ihren sitz nicht in
deutschland wir haben in unserem land
über gewinne wenn man das so nennen will
also sehr hohe gewinne bei impfstoff
produzenten wir haben hohe gewinne auch
bei denen bei den produzenten von von
windkraft aber wenn der staat beginnt zu
entscheiden welcher gewinnes akzeptabel
und welcher nicht liefern wir unser
steuerrecht der willkür aus und übrigens
beschädigen wir auch den
innovationsstandort deutschland denn wir
wollen ja innovative unternehmen wie bei
und tag bei uns haben die briten haben
da kein problem mit und die irgendwie in
das sag ich schon die italiener schaffen
es auch sehr gut dieses
gewinnverlagerung problem zu umgehen
indem sie den umsatz besteuern also man
könnte schon wenn man wollte wer genau
hinsieht stellt fest dass es in italien
große probleme bei der erhebung gibt und
in frankreich hat sich das parlament
gerade aus diesen gründen gegen eine
über gewinn steuer entschieden herr
lindner danke für das gespräch ich danke
ihnen auch
das interview haben wir vor einer stunde
geführt es sind jedenfalls ungemütliche
zeiten angebrochen die energiekosten
werden viele hart treffen der
wirtschaftsminister ist ja seit monaten
im dauereinsatz
als handlungsreisender in sachen
gasimporte von norwegen bis katar
clapper tabak alle möglichen anbieter
habt und das in einem solchen tempo an
deutschen küsten lng terminals für die
anlieferung von flüssiggas geplant
werden das hätte man sich vor einem
halben jahr auch noch nicht vorstellen
können in dieser lage lohnt sich aber
auch ein blick ins eigene land auf
deutsche biogas anlagen so gewissermaßen
aus mais und misst gold gemacht wird
oliver berichtet
es wäre eine nahezu perfekte
kreislaufwirtschaft einzig aus gülle und
mist bio energie zu produzieren also
verflüssigtes gas mit dem lkw und busse
fahren können genau das macht kunibert
ruhe auf seiner biogasanlage im
niedersächsischen ruhe früher mal
landwirt dann biogasanlagenbauer
entwickelte und vertreibt das modul dass
das biogas auf minus 151 grad
herunterkühlt und dann verflüssigt wir
haben eine lösung gesucht was wir mit
biogasanlagen nach dem ablauf des eeg es
machen sprich wenn die anlage 20 jahre
am laufen sind bekommen die ja keine
gesicherte vergütung mehr und wir haben
uns für das thema bioenergie entschieden
um dieses biologie auch im verkehr viel
schwerlastverkehr zu produzieren um co2
dementsprechend zu reduzieren die
biogasanlage in darchau die das lg
ausschließlich aus abfällen wie gülle
oder mist produziert soll pro jahr etwa
1,3 millionen liter fossilen diesel
kraftstoff ersetzen und bis zu 7000
tonnen co2 einsparen verglichen mit den
148 millionen tonnen co2 die im
vergangenen jahr in deutschland im
verkehrssektor ausgestoßen wurden nur
ein tropfen auf den heißen stein aber
kleinvieh macht auch mist und es ist ja
erst der anfang wenn wir die ganze gülle
und mist aus der landwirtschaft zu bio
energie verwandelt werden umwandeln
würden dafür haben wir unsere
biogasanlage dafür brauchen wir keine
neuen bios anlagen bauen sondern nur
dies ergänzen dann können wir 35 prozent
des dieses wird für die lkws ersetzen
der tankstellenbetreiber q1 wird das in
darchau produzierte bio energie
vertreiben es sei eine win win situation
unser ziel jetzt unternehmen ist es bis
2035 bereits ein klimaneutrales
produktportfolio anbieten zu können und
da ist bio energie einfach der
schnellsten mögliche weg im verkehr um
treibhausgasemissionen zu senken
aus bio gas lng für den verkehrssektor
zu produzieren der falsche weg
kritisieren umweltschützer beim abkühlen
des biogases um daraus energie zu
bekommen entstehen wieder energie
verluste und andererseits brauchen wir
die biogasanlagen grad zur
stromerzeugung und bei der
stromerzeugung wird auch abwärme erzeugt
und diese wärme brauchen wir im
wärmesektor zum beispiel mit hilfe von
wärmenetzen
2020 importierte deutschland
56,3 milliarden kubikmeter erdgas aus
russland stattliche 15 milliarden
kubikmeter wurden im selben jahr von den
deutschen biogas anlagen produziert
sollten sie ihren betrieb wegen des
wegfalls der eeg-umlage einstellen wäre
die versorgungssicherheit in deutschland
dramatisch gefährdet
haben die abhängigkeit vom russischen
gas jungs und diese missliche lage
gebracht hat wird uns nun zum blick auf
russlands krieg in der ukraine damit
beginnt die nachrichten heims nach den
schweren explosionen auf einem
militärstützpunkt auf der von russland
annektierten halbinsel krim haben die
behörden dort den ausnahmezustand
ausgerufen nach angaben des örtlichen
verwaltungschefs kam ein mensch ums
leben 14 wurden verletzt die ursache für
die explosionen ist weiter unklar
unübersichtlich ist auch die situation
an von russland besetzten atomkraftwerks
apres ski ab das vor einigen tagen
beschlossen wurde die g7 staaten haben
russland aufgefordert das atomkraftwerk
unverzüglich wieder der vollständigen
kontrolle der ukraine zu unterstellen
und sie warnten vor dem risiko eines
nuklearen zwischenfall
us-verteidigungsminister osten hat der
ukraine erneut eine lang anhaltende
unterstützung zugesichert austin war
heute zu einem besuch in der lettischen
hauptstadt riga und sicherte auch
lettland die solidarität der usa zu
lettland gehört seit 2004 eu und nato an
es grenzt an russland und dessen
verbündeten belarus
china hat seine militärübungen rundum
teilbar nach und einer woche vorerst für
abgeschlossen erklärt china hatte die
manöver nachdem taiwan besuch der
us-politikerin nancy pelosi begonnen
taiwan erklärte derartige besuche seien
üblich und china nutze per los reise nur
als vorwand um seine bedrohungen zu
steigern
in nordrhein-westfalen hat nach den
sommerferien heute wieder die schule
begonnen und damit auch die debatte über
die korona schutzpläne der bundesverband
der kinder und jugendärzte will keine
masken pflicht für schüler im herbst und
winter
bundesbildungsministerin stark watzinger
schloss aus dass wegen corona wieder
schulen flächendeckend zu bleiben
könnten falls lehrkräfte ausfüllen
sollte der unterricht auch mittels
digitaler medien möglich sein
eigentlich waren die waldbrände im
südwesten frankreichs schon gelöscht nun
ist eines der zwei großen feuer wieder
aufgeflammt mehr als 3800 menschen
mussten zur sicherheit ihre häuser
verlassen und 6000 hektar sind bereits
zerstört im waldgebiet südlich von
bordeaux sind gleich drei gemeinden in
gefahr eine neue hitzewelle erschwert
die löscharbeiten bis sonntag soll es in
der gegend temperaturen an die 40 grad
geht
die waffenruhe in nahost bleibt wackelig
auch wenn die israelische armee ihre
dreitägige operation im gazastreifen
militärische als erfolg werden kann sie
hatte gezielt führungsleute und
nachschubwege der terror gruppe
palästinensischer islamischer jihad
attackiert aufeinander stiller duldung
der konkurrierenden hamas die jedenfalls
selbst nicht eingriff die raketen die
daraufhin nach israel flogen sollen alle
von der dschihad gruppe stamm und es war
nach israelischen angaben eine solche
rakete die fehlgeleitet wurde und nicht
nach israel flog sondern in einer gasse
in gaza ein schluck grausamen folgen
dieser explosion machen nun weltweit
schlagzeilen und die opfer werden zum
politikum andreas kienast war für uns in
gaza
auf der fahrt durch dabei ja durch diese
überlaufenen überladene
flüchtlingsschiff im norden des gaza
streifen erinnert so lange nichts an die
raketen an den tod an den wahnsinn des
vergangenen wochenendes bis man
plötzlich vor einem trauerzelt steht
aufgeschlagen von den nachbarn zur
erinnerung an den vater und die fünf
söhne starben
die jungs waren genauso frech wie ihre
freunde sie hatten keine chance am
samstagabend kurz nach einbruch der
dunkelheit
explodierte die gasse fünf menschen tot
und zwei schwer verletzt
der eine ein junge spielte koste alberta
wie sie
das mädchen war drin und sollte
rausgehen um ihren bruder zum abendessen
zu rufen das mädchen heißt wahrhaft es
ist elf jahre alt und geht in die
sechste klasse es herrscht stille
beklommenheit als die kamera ins
krankenzimmer kommt dann nimmt die
mutter die decke weg die welt soll es
sehen die ärzte haben ra half beide
beine amputiert und den rechten arm als
die rakete explodiert war sind die
eltern hinaus gerannt haben gerufen
gesucht geweint
und bruder haben wir gefunden er war
voller blut aber er lebte wir haben
gewartet bis der krankenwagen kam dann
haben wir weiter nach half gesucht nach
zwei stunden haben wir sie im
krankenhaus gefunden ohne beine mit nur
einem arm
die rakete von dschabalija die rakete
die reha verstümmelt hat ist die
politischste die umstrittenste des
jüngsten konflikts denn niemand will sie
abgefeuert
der islamische dschihad beschuldigt
israel aber israel veröffentlicht dieses
video es soll beweisen dass die rakete
in gaza gestartet aber fehl gesteuert
war und im dicht besiedelten giabbani
dagegen
zwei kilometer weiter einen halben tag
früher haben die israelis das haus von
potash am dach zerstört sie waren es
sicher denn sie haben vorher angerufen
mein handy hat geklingelt
salam aleikum du hast zwei minuten um
dein haus zu evakuieren eine männliche
stimme die nummer anonyme oder scham
lack hat seine familie und das handy
geschnappt und zugesehen wie sein haus
in die luft fliegt
warum wisse er nicht und terroristen die
nachbarn vielleicht nicht dass er wüsste
die frage nach schuld zerreißt den nahen
osten schuld am terror schuld an den
raketen wer immer es war in dschabalija
am vergangenen samstag hat er die
unschuldigen getroffen
und jetzt macht nochmal heinz wolf
walther die inflation in deutschland war
vorhin in der sendung schon thema jetzt
zur situation in den usa dort gab es
heute neue inflationsdaten und demnach
war die preissteigerung zuletzt
niedriger als erwartet frank wittmann
was lässt sich daraus für die weitere
entwicklung ablesen die neusten zahlen
nähren die hoffnung dass die teuerung
die ihren höhepunkt erreicht haben
könnte vor allem die energie- und
spritpreise sind gesunken bereits seit
einigen wochen fallen die preise an den
amerikanischen tankstellen so das die
inflationsrate nun zwar immer noch bei
8,5 prozent liegt nach allerdings 9,1
prozent im juni der scheitelpunkt der
inflationswelle ist vorüber ist sich
deka chefvolkswirt ulrich kater sicher
trotzdem wird es noch ein langer weg bis
die inflation wieder bei 2 prozent
angekommen ist das gilt für die
vereinigten staaten wie für den euroraum
waren hierzulande ist das
inflationsgespenst noch längst nicht
verscheucht maßnahmen wie der tank
rabatt und das neun euro ticket haben
zwar für entlastung gesorgt aber nur
vorübergehend bereits im oktober sind
durch die geplante gas umlage weitere
preissteigerungen kaum vermeidbar das
signal aus amerika beflügelt die börsen
heute dennoch der dax legt 1,2 prozent
der dow jones index sogar 1,5 prozent zu
das kalkül der anleger steigen die
preise nicht mehr ganz so stark muss
möglicherweise die us notenbank auch
nicht mehr ganz so stark gegenlenken
dass sie weiter die leitzinsen anheben
wird steht hingegen außer frage
diskutiert wird nur wie groß fallen die
nächsten schritte aus frank bethmann
vielen dank
mehr öffentliche gratis
trinkwasserbrunnen in deutschland das
sieht ein gesetzentwurf von
bundesumweltministerin lemke vor der
heute das kabinett passiert hat kommunen
sollen künftig verpflichtet werden noch
mehr öffentlich zugängliche brunnen in
parks und fußgängerzonen oder
einkaufspassagen zur verfügung zu
stellen in anbetracht der anhaltenden
hitzewellen sollen die brunnen teil
einer hitze vorsorge sein
und jetzt die zahlen vom lotto am
mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr 10 18 22 24 26 27 und die
superzahl 2 weitere gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lotte punkt zdf de und im zdf
text auf seite 55 7
nicht nur hamburg trauert um uwe seeler
und uwe jetzt praktisch von einer ganzen
nation so genannt wurde hat sehr viel
richtig gemacht in seinem leben nicht
nur herausragendes geleistet dafür
erntet man respekt oder bewunderung aber
ja nicht automatisch auch eine solche
zuneigung er war einfach ein wirklich
netter mensch ein feiner charakter sagen
die die ihn gekannt haben und das
spürten auch die die ihn nur aus der
ferne liebten und verehrten als ikone
des deutschen fußballs
seine stadt seinen hamburg hat sich
heute von ihm verabschiedet ralf
zimmermann von sefa dort seien
übergroßer bronze fuß am volkspark
stadion ist seit seinem tod nun
endgültig zur wallfahrtsstätte geworden
uns uwe da sind sich die fans einig wird
für immer leben ein leben wie es in
keinem buche steht er hat für fairness
gestanden er war
ja er war unser hamburger sage ich mal
und
ist normal geblieben auf dem
bodenständig er ist wirklich so einer
von nebenan ein echter wahrer freund uns
uwe
im hsv stadion hatte sich nicht nur die
deutsche fußball prominenz mit flick
kahn & co versammelt auch der kanzler
gehört heute zum letzten geleit des
hamburger ehrenbürgers und ein sichtlich
betroffener bürgermeister der stadt die
uwe seeler für kein geld der welt je
verlassen wollte daniela wir alle
möchten ihnen ausdrücklich danken denn
es ist sicher nicht immer leicht einen
so bekannten ehemann und vater zu haben
ein mann der bis ins hohe alter in der
öffentlichkeit stand und sich für den
sport für seine stadt und seinen hsv
engagiert hat
fußballerisch ein genius dessen tore in
den 60ern bis heute legendär sind und
denen das große geld beispielsweise im
italienischen fussball nie in
verlegenheit gebracht hatte und einer
der seine überzeugungen immer mit einer
prise humor würzte
die spieler sollen bombe ich verdiene
aber ich glaube wir müssen aufpassen
dass wir nicht übertragen
das ist das wieder hier einzige wohl
verzichten kann denn
fußball ist fußball aber es nicht nur
geld international blieb ihm ein spitzen
titel versagt wembley 66 wurde seine
größte niederlage mentale stärke
vielleicht auch deshalb zu einem seiner
markenzeichen den größten titel von
allen kann man überhaupt nicht gewinnen
er wird einem verliehen von den menschen
von den fans und er kommt von herzen und
dann sprach noch einer heute beim
abschied nehmen den fans aus dem herzen
ich weiß lieber uwe du schaust jetzt
davon da oben herunter und du erhältst
die hand über hamburg über dieses
stadion über ein hsv über seine treuen
fans bilder aus seinen ersten jahren in
der nationalmannschaft eine seiner
lebensweisheiten sollte man sich ganz
besonders merken
es war ein trauriger tag in hamburg und
trotzdem irgendwie auch ein fröhlicher
im gedenken an einen danny verzagte
deine
[Musik]
das war es im heute journal und gleich
gehts dem auslandsjournal weiter mit
einer dokumentation über die lage in
afghanistan
katrin eigendorf und sebastian barren
zwei wochen dort unterwegs und zeigen
wie tiefgreifend die taliban das land
bereits verändert kann
ja und wir melden uns dann morgen wieder
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter europaweit
herrscht ja eine extreme dürre und auch
in deutschland ist viel zu wenig regen
gefallen 103 liter auf den quadratmeter
im mittel gab es bisher das ist der
meteorologische sommer vom erster juni
und der geht bis ende august also ein
paar wochen haben wir noch und dass wir
den absoluten rekord von 130 litern
unterbieten dafür stehen die chancen
leider gut und das liegt daran dass ein
umfangreiches hoch sich ausgebildet hat
wir haben eine kräftige östliche
strömung dazu und das hitze tief was
sich wieder bereit macht über spanien
für die nächste hitzewelle in der nacht
gibt es wenige wolken es ist trocken
aber im süden kräftigen wind mit dieser
östlichen strömung teils in den bergen
stürmischen wind und das bei
temperaturen von neun grad am alpenrand
und 18 grad im rhein-main-gebiet ja und
morgen gibt es viel sonne und weiterhin
im süden kräftigen wind über der
schwäbischen alb zum beispiel vor allem
in den höheren lagen dann stürmische
böen aus östlichen richtungen
dazu temperaturen im südwesten weil 32
grad da kommt der wind gelegen das
temperaturempfinden ist etwas
erträglicher
24 grad an der ostsee und 34 grad am
niederrhein die kommenden tage viel
sonnenschein und hitze bis 34 grad
einzelne hitzegewitter im süden
deutschlands oder ansonsten steigen die
temperaturen am sonntag bis 35 grad ein
schöner ab